today is May 4th also known as Star Wars
day and to celebrate the Viva Las Vegas
wedding chapel has Star Wars wedding
specials so they include of course a
course of Star Wars themed ceremony
performed by Anakin Skywalker or better
known as Darth Vader we sent eight news
now reporter Brian wildown to the Chapel
to catch up with a couple
[Music]
experience our youngest son is
what we're going to be right if we had a
got married by Darth Vader
in this town where everything is
entertainment and this is the way to do
your wedding
[Music]
May the fourth be with you
the walk down the aisle the smoke
machine they go all out right yeah it
was the couple's first time in Las Vegas
they traveled with their family from
England to have their wedding and the
honeymoon here prices for that wedding
ranged from 150 to 860 dollars worth it
for Star Wars fans you can have your
picture with Darth Vader it's a great
wedding photo and you'll never forget it
right yeah typical Vegas yeah I have a
question for you when he Darth Vader
lights up the lightsaber did you go back
to age eight oh gosh just ready to go in
there but my feet couldn't even touch
them when I was watching Stars my feet
couldn't be tested around